hey good folks dr john deloney here with
ramsey solutions
the last few videos we've been talking
about grief how to process grief
being with others while you're grieving
and all of us
are grieving during this pandemic
nonsense mess
i've been taking calls in the radio
booth and i want you to
watch this call two people a husband
wrestling with love and care for his
wife and they're hurting
and it has everything to do with grief
take a look how long have you all been
married
uh just over nine years nine years so
when did
when did depression anxiety it just it
usually doesn't just pop
up um have you seen this is this a
family history for her
um what give me give me kind of the arc
of the depression anxiety that showed up
so um her her parents
do struggle with depression and anxiety
her
mother has a number of different health
conditions and um
you know that contribute to that i
really didn't notice anything and maybe
that's just
from me being a dumb oblivious husband i
don't know but
welcome to the club yeah um
i really didn't notice anything until um
october of 2018 which actually coincided
with
the month that we got out of debt she
started to
to to say things of i just don't
feel right i don't feel
um i'm you know i'm having
you know difficulty sometimes getting
out of bed and
and um you know it's just
very she wasn't feeling herself she was
she's always been very
involved in teaching some of the youth
of our church
she does an early morning seminary class
she did an early morning seminary class
that was
teaching some of the youth and that was
a very that's something that she's
always been very passionate about and
she was having a hard time
getting into it and um
so what's your role what what role have
you played the last couple years
yeah uh in in trying to help her with
that or or
contributing to that or i guess what are
you both yeah
the word you the phrase you just you
just used gave me a clue
what does help look like for you
i i i don't i don't know you know like a
lot of husbands i'm
i'm a fixer at heart and
i know that that doesn't work i know
that that doesn't
actually help anything but i just i
don't know
what to do i don't know how to
how to reach her because
she just when she gets into those
depressive episodes
she just starts to run herself down
and she starts talking about
that i need to divorce her because
she's because i can do so much better
and and it just
i don't know what to do in those moments
yeah i don't want my marriage to end
well the fact that you're reaching out
and calling tells me it's not going to
because you're invested in it okay
and i want to tell you on behalf of all
the guys listening to this
that i'm proud of the step that you're
taking because it's a big step and it's
a hard step
it's a hard step that way way way too
many husbands don't do
so the fact that you're still vested
makes my heart full so here's
you nailed it um
let me back up and tell you this
depression and anxiety at the end of the
day
all anxiety is is it's a fire alarm
it just is a um i hate it as a diagnosis
i hate depression as a diagnosis because
it
it it tattoos somebody with a with a
with a
with a temporary state with a permanent
label
and when we have
ups and downs in life um do you have any
kids
yeah we have one child okay um had y'all
planned to have more
have you had fertility issues have you
had challenges there
yeah okay so when you get into things
like fertility challenges
identity issues who are we it is year
seven of our marriage
we had this huge goal to get out of debt
and we got there and we were hoping that
this external plug was gonna fill
some internal identity holes that we
have all of a sudden
the air just starts getting let out of
the balloon and
when i as a husband um
when we went through multiple
miscarriages and multiple i thought we
were gonna have this many kids and
suddenly we didn't
i missed the the um
identity assault on my wife by a and i
do crisis for a living man
and i missed it by 10 football fields i
just missed it
um and then i started trying to solve
some of these challenges with logic
and so all depression anxiety is is an
alarm system
and they are disconnection disorders
that means that somebody is untethered
and unplugged
and so for somebody like you somebody
like me who looks at a problem and tries
to solve it with
logic solve it with if you just do this
what that does is it tends to take
somebody who's struggling and looping
out and frustrated and says things that
they don't really mean like dude just
run from me because i'm not worth you
being here
um that is somebody trying to tether in
and so
a couple of things high five to you for
seeking a professional help i think
that's the right thing for you and i
think it would be helpful for you to
both go
at some point um together i think that's
why so start with the university list
and get a list of counselors in your
area the second thing is this
i want you to do something every day
twice a day
for the next week or two three weeks and
you can say hey dude this knucklehead
pseudo dock on the radio told me to do
this and so we have to
and all i want you to do is in the
morning and in the evening
twice a day i want you to hold her hands
and i want you to look her in the eye
and say
tell me how today is and when it's over
y'all can laugh you can be all silly you
can get teary whatever that is i want
you to hold her hands
make skin to skin contact look her in
the eye and say how's your day going
and then when she gives you an answer at
the end you all you can say is
thank you for sharing that that's it i'm
not going to give any advice i'm not
going to give you solutions i'm not
going to give you any you know what you
should be
just say thank you for sharing that and
what's going to happen
hopefully over the next couple of weeks
is these tiny
tiny little tentacles of connection are
going to start making their way across
your marriage again and that's how
you're going to heal from the inside out
you got to get professional help on this
one i think having a counselor you trust
is wise and smart
but start with skin on skin contact look
in their eyes and don't look to solve
this problem look to connect
from the inside out what a lovely guy
what a lovely couple
anytime somebody has a picture of what
tomorrow's gonna look like whether
that's
they're gonna be holding a loved one
whether that's
they're gonna be graduating whether
that's
they're gonna have a house full of kids
running around laughing
knocking things over causing problems
anytime somebody has a picture of
tomorrow and that picture changes
gets ripped out from under him slowly
quickly
that's grief and you feel that pain
which again pain just points to
something that you loved
and when it goes away if you don't
properly grieve if you don't
process the fact that the pictures
changed on us and we have to do the hard
painful ugly work of recreating and
dreaming about a new picture
to live into then it will come out in
all sorts of different places
this is a gross word that they usually
use for dirty diapers but we call it
leakage in counseling
if you don't properly deal with your
feelings with the pain you have inside
it will come out and it will come out in
weird places
it will even come out like in the last
call
where a wife who loves her husband looks
at him and says
you're just better off leaving me just
go
and you can hear the tears of a husband
as he's saying
i don't want to go i want to love you
and i take care of you
and i don't know how so you heard me
tell them
often i don't want to gender this but
often guys try to solve problems with
with
math right they try to try to articulate
you should be exercising and working out
and eating properly
that's the way to and man when you're
grieving when you're hurting
sometimes math isn't the answer
connection is
i you heard me tell the caller i want
you to hold your wife's hands
i want you to look her in the eye and
say how are you
i love you how are things going
and then when she tells you no answers
no advice
just thank you for sharing that's it
that
starts the roots of connection that
starts the roots of one person look into
the soul of another person and saying
how are you i'm here for you
not my advice not my solutions not my
answers
but me and then an issue like fertility
not only are you grieving this idea this
loss of my body was designed for one
thing and i can't do that one thing
that's a loss
but you're also going to grieve this
picture right this imaginary
thanksgiving table that's never going to
be full this
high school graduations that you're not
going to attend in the future weddings
you're not going to right
so you're grieving lost pictures lost
ideas loss of dreams
it's bigger than just the incident and
we often focus on grief
like what's happening right now i didn't
get to go to my birthday
i didn't get to have easter and the way
i normally have easter i
just lost to my job it's bigger than
that
we have to collectively grieve we lost
control
we lost this illusion that most medical
problems going to be okay
most economic problems are going to be
okay because we got sideswiped by this
deal we didn't see it coming
and here it is so we have to properly
understand and grieve
our future's going to look different now
and we're going to do it together and
then
we're gonna go be brave and then we're
gonna work together
with our community with our friends with
our co-workers with our
families and we're gonna start the
building blocks of building what
tomorrow's gonna look like
we're gonna do it together that's what
bravery looks like
this is john delony thank you so much
for joining us i'll see you next time
don't forget subscribe below
all the below things don't forget um if
you want to know more about grief
feelings all the things if you haven't
read it by now seriously what are you
doing with your life
right um if you're watching the dance
the last dance on espn
that's fair because that's actually been
a really good docu series other than
that read the article and subscribe to
the youtube channel and
follow me at john dalone and all the
things i'll see you next time take care